bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 18 janvier la
vaccination ouverte à plus de 6 millions
de français depuis aujourd'hui si la
population semble moins réticentes les
élus eux s'inquiètent du faible nombre
de doses reçues et le temps presse face
aux variants notamment britannique qui
deviendrait dominant en france entre fin
février et mi mars selon l'inserm le
haut conseil de santé publique
recommande de ne plus utiliser de masque
en tissu et de garder deux mètres de
distance pour faire face à cette
nouvelle menace
[Musique]
j - 2 avant l'investiture de joe biden
aux etats unis une prestation de serment
sous très haute sécurité dans une
capitale désertée mais quadrillée par
l'armée à joe biden et kamala harris
deviendront mercredi président et
vice-présidente des etats-unis donnent
un tram sera lui le grand absent de ce
passage de témoin quant à ses partisans
réseau signé entre soutien et
résignation dans les fiefs républicains
alexis alexeï navalni placé en détention
jusqu'au 15 février l'opposant politique
russe avait été arrêtée hier soir à
moscou à sa descente d'avion pour avoir
violé les conditions d'une peine de
prison avec sursis
l'union européenne condamne son
arrestation et demande sa libération
immédiate
[Musique]
coup d'envoi aujourd'hui en france de la
campagne make signal antico vide 19 pour
les plus de 75 ans et des personnes
dites à haut risque on retrouve notre
reporter david kelly faron direct depuis
le ministère de la santé
bonsoir david comment s'est passée cette
première journée de vaccination grand
public la logistique à titre d'exemple
dans la mairie du 15e arrondissement de
paris de la série s'est transformée en
centre de vaccination
ça rappelle à toute une équipe médicale
créée à des zones spécifiques afin que
les patients puissent recevoir la dose
en toute sécurité installé des
congélateurs pour pouvoir stocker ces
doses de vaccin faire connaissance avec
le logiciel mise à disposition par
l'état et tout ça en un temps record
vous imaginez que ce n'est pas simple
pour lui le mairie malgré ça beaucoup de
personnes se sont pressées devant la
mairie puisque le service téléphoniques
étaient saturées pour seulement
décrocher un rendez vous pour les
passions chanceux qui ont pu recevoir le
sésame est bien même la haye la prise en
charge des patients a été très compliqué
c'est un sentiment partagé aujourd'hui
qui résulte entre eux les premiers
services donc entre le soulagement des
premiers servis et ceux qui cherchent
encore à décrocher un rendez vous
écouter à mon dernier passage à la
mairie on m'a donné une feuille en
disant faites ce numéro de téléphone
commencé à appeler à 8h30 on va vous
contacte et on va fixer un rendez vous
bon je me suis levé de bonne heure pour
être à l'heure de j'ai commencé à
téléphoner à 20 heures du matin jusqu'à
12h45 à chaque fois le téléphone sonne
et sony sony au bout de quelques tombes
disait c'est ont compris il ya trop de
demandes
attendez un peu on vous rappelle on vous
rappelle j'en ai marre j'ai laissé
tomber on m'a dit non non c'est on va
pas vous vacciner tout de suite on va
prendre vos coordonnées on vous tiendra
au courant vous téléphone tu parles moi
je ne crois pas à leur téléphone
ils vont chanter m'appeler peut-être ils
m'appelleront le jour mais les héritiers
vont lui dire ça y est elle est morte
fut donc ta parcours du combattant
au tout début en arrivant à la mairie du
15e pour me renseigner à quel endroit on
devait se faire vacciner
et là je reconnais qu'il ya eu une
période de flottement à la cub et que je
me mettrai sur le
sur le fait que c'était un début c'est
le premier jour et contrairement à
beaucoup de gens je je vais faire la
déclaration suivante je suis très
optimiste pour 7,7 ce début de
vaccination et je crois que le message
qu'il faut faire passer à tout un chacun
sait que il faut avoir un peu pas de
science mais tout le monde va arriver à
ce qu'il désire c'est à dire sans sortir
au plus vite de cette de cette saloperie
du côté de la mairie on pointe du doigt
encore une fois un manque d'anticipation
de la part du gouvernement mais surtout
un manque de confiance envers les
collectivités locales et on craint de
prendre beaucoup de retard dans cette
campagne de vaccination adressé aux
personnes âgées aux personnes à risque
c'est en tout cas l'avis du maire du
xvème arrondissement équipe
m nous avons dû aménager les salles les
files actives
nous avons dû acheter des réfrigérateurs
nous avons dû demander rechercher les
médecins les infirmières mettre en place
tous les systèmes techniques
technologiques nécessaires
les services de sécurité enfin bref tout
était organisé par nous mêmes l'état
nous fournissant les doses mais nous
sommes un centre de vaccination ou à
plein régime
tout était prévu pour vacciner mille
personnes par jour et malheureusement
nous allons recevoir seulement 500 doses
par semaine ce qui nous permettra de
vacciner uniquement 80 personnes par
jour au lieu de 1000 je crois que c'est
le manque d'anticipation comme on l'a vu
pour les masques ou pour les dépistages
au début en tout cas mais aussi
peut-être plus structurellement à un
manque de confiance de l'autorité
administrative par rapport aux
collectivités locales l'état trop
centralisateur trop bureaucratique
n'arrive pas finalement à être
suffisamment souple et réactif pour
organiser les
nécessité de la crise or nous petites
entités
nous sommes très réactifs très souple
d'emplois et donc près du terrain nous
pouvons mettre en place des choses
beaucoup plus rapidement et pour cette
première journée ce sont près de 25
personnes qui ont pu être vaccinés dans
ce centre bien loin des 80 personnes
espérées et c'est le même son de cloche
à travers la france au total pour rappel
ce sont plus de 6 millions de personnes
qui sont concernées par cette campagne
de vaccination faire cette première
étape de campagne de vaccination public
mais les délais imposés par le
gouvernement inquiète
chez les collectivités locales et dans
les mairies également merci beaucoup
david kelly fin et on continue de parler
de cette campagne de vaccination qui a
qui connaît un début difficile avec
vincent jean brun maire de l'haÿ les
roses dans le val de marne président du
groupe libre républicains et
indépendants au conseil régional d'île
de france et notre rubrique l'invité ce
soir
bon froid vincent genvrin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on a
entendu vos collègues élus parisiens
notamment vivent des situations un petit
peu rocambolesque aujourd'hui je crois
savoir que ça a été un petit peu votre
cas aussi à l'ail et les roses
manifestement ce que vous entendez
pardon j'ai eu un petit souci de votre
réponse oui est ce que vous nous
entendez voilà alors je me sens et voit
la section sol très bien voilà mon
intervention cafouille un peu comme
c'est le cas pour cette campagne
vaccinale qui démarre effectivement de
manière bien étrange puisque on se rend
compte que tout a été improvisée il ya
quinze jours de cela le gouvernement
disait on n'a pas besoin des mers pas
besoin des collectivités locales il
balayait d'un revers de main les
propositions dead il compris les régions
notamment dans la région ile de france
et puis lundi dernier coup de téléphone
on nous dit ah on a besoin de vous est
ce que vous acceptez d'être des
partenaires de l'état
évidemment on dit oui parce qu'on veut
protéger nos populations et être les
plus réactifs mais on s'attendait des
partenaires c'est à dire que chacun
fasse un bout du chemin
un bout quelque chose or force est de
constater qu'en réalité on gère tout de
a à z de l'inscription qui est chaotique
en passant par la mobilisation des
médecins et des soignants en passant par
l'organisation de toute la logistique en
inde est en étendant la commande des
seringue des cotons et jusqu'à là et
c'est l'anecdote du jour aller chercher
nous mêmes les vaccins qui a même pas de
service de livraison des vaccins
j'étais moi même en tant que maire dans
ma petite zoé sur les routes ce matin
pour aller à l'hôpital sainte-anne
récupérer mes 25 petites doses de vaccin
on voit bien qu'il ya un vrai sujet à
une vraie improvisation c'est ça
pourrait prêter à rire s'il n'y avait
pas des vies derrière et des enjeux
considérables notamment la possibilité
pour notre pays de se sortir enfin de
cette crise de redémarrer et de
retrouver un semblant de vie normale et
une économie florissante à nouveau alors
question peut-être naïve mais
vous êtes allé chercher ses vaccins
qu'on doit conserver à moins 80 degrés
je crois dans votre voiture personnelle
mais c'est en fait les vaccins une fois
décongelés ont une durée de vie de cinq
jours donc en réalité on nous a remis
des doses décongeler qu'il faut
conserver entre 4 et 8 degrés c'est à
dire au frigo dans un swing aux normales
par contre on a donc cinq jours
uniquement
et une fois que la petite fiole est
ouverte on a globalement six heures pour
injecter le vaccin
donc oui on peut aller avec un véhicule
normal effectivement nous on était venu
plein d'espoir avec deux belles grosses
glaciaire en disant on va revenir avec
plein de vaccins pour vacciner notre
population et la vérité cette
globalement on m'a remis une petite
boîte de chocolats de petites 25 toute
petite dose donc c'est vrai que tous
avaient à l'est un semblant un peu
ridicule donc on est heureux d'avoir pu
commencer les vaccinations aujourd'hui
mais alors qu'en une seule journée
vendredi dernier j'ai eu quatre mille
inscriptions
globalement on a réussi à faire 25
piqûre aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
commencé à 13 heures et avec le peu de
doses que nous avons on en aura à peine
une cinquantaine demain envoyer 4000
inscrits 50 doses par jour
il ya quelque chose qui va pas vers
saint-jean bras est ce que vous vous
expliquer où l'on vous a expliqué
pourquoi vous avez été aussi peu livrés
non je ne le comprends pas parce que il
ya une incohérence entre le chiffre
qu'on nous annonce à l'échelle globale à
l'échelle des régions et ce qu'on voit
réellement sur le terrain
et l'explication qu'on est en train de
se donner et j'ai entendu à travers des
interventions de certains représentants
de la majorité qui était sur les
plateaux télé envoyé un peu en mission
kamikaze ce week end ils ont commencé à
nous expliquer qu'en fait on gérer la
pénurie en bon père de famille parce que
on voulait être sûre de ne jamais
manquer de vaccins
donc c'est très drôle parce que moi j'ai
la conviction qu'au contraire on devrait
vacciner 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
pour essayer de vacciner la population
le plus vite possible et à côté de ça
mon ami de la santé que ninard vous
inquiétez pas on théorise on met de côté
en stock pour être sûr de janin a manqué
mais en fait de fait on en manque sur le
terrain et c'est assez terrible et on
peut imaginer qu'ils en stock
parce qu'ils ne sont pas certains de la
filière d'approvisionnement et que comme
vous le savez ce vaccin nécessite deux
ans deux injections et que en gros pour
chaque injection
7la dans ses quatre premières semaines
ils stockent l'équivalent pour qu'on
puisse continuer à faire la deuxième
injection
ça peut être logique si effectivement
ils ont des craintes mais ça veut dire
qu'ils devraient le dire à la population
doit être transparent dix ans on pense
ne sera pas livré de tout ce qu'on
attendait justement vous êtes sur la
même ligne que la maire de lille martine
aubry qui a réagi vivement ce matin on
l'écoutait nous pouvons faire beaucoup
plus à condition d'avoir les vaccins je
suis inquiète que le gouvernement dise
la vérité sur le nombre de vaccins
disponibles
vincent jean - vous avez aussi le
sentiment à l'instar de martine aubry on
ne dit pas toute la vérité vous l'a
réclamé au gouvernement aujourd'hui
absolue bon moi je les accuse pas
d'irriter je pense que ne nous disent
pas les problèmes qu'ils rencontrent
notamment le fait qu'ils ont démarré
tout ça trop tard
on a reçu nos vaccins en france en même
temps que tous les autres pays européens
la livraison est effectuée le même jour
par tout simplement voit bien que les
autres pays sont ont démarré au quart de
tour et que nous on est à la traîne
donc on a envie déjà de les entendre et
moi j'aurais envie d'entendre un mea
culpa
oui on a mal géré et oui on démarre mal
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
appelé les maires à la rescousse en
catastrophe et qu'on leur demande de
tout gérer de a à z
moi je vous lis très clair loin j'aurai
passé comment directement au laboratoire
c'était pareil y'a pas une aide
supplémentaire qui est intervenu pour
aider les collectivités à mettre les
choses en place
donc il ya cette première problématique
de on n'a pas des aides on est on a
démarré en retard
et puis derrière on voudrait avoir la
vérité sur le calendrier parce que quand
on nous dit ne vous inquiétez pas il y
aura un million de vaccinés en fin
janvier
imaginons mais la vérité sexy janvier
c'est à dire qu'on aura que 1 million
fin février puisque avec ce système de
deux injections pour être vraiment
vacciner ça veut dire que concrètement
il va falloir refaire passer tous ceux
qui ont été vaccinés la première fois
donc on bloque toute la filière et pour
vous dire les choses simplement à l'haÿ
les roses
comme pour martine aubry on était
dimensionnée pour 200 injections par
jour
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
on va au mieux réussir en faire une
cinquantaine on va voyez bien que
j'aille à un premier écart et
deuxièmement quand bien même j'aurais
réussi à vacciner 200 personnes par jour
au bout de quatre semaines
eh bien il faut s'arrêter et reprendre
au début ça veut dire qu'effectivement
en fait on va paralyser le système si on
n'a pas de nouvelles doses à chaque fois
qu'on interpelle le gouvernement
à chaque fois qu'on interpelle les
services de l'état il nous confirme que
pour l'instant ils n'ont pas plus de 2
merci beaucoup en tout cas vincent jean
bras nous avoir apporté votre expérience
précieuse de terrain merci d'avoir été
en direct avec nous assure rt france et
on aura compris entre vaccins et variant
c'est une véritable course contre la
montre pour le gouvernement mais aussi
pour les élus comme on l'a entendu ou
pour le personnel soignant pour parler
de cette campagne vaccinale à laquelle
adhèrent de plus en plus de français
d'ailleurs place à notre décryptage avec
nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
pierre laurent sénateur pcf de paris
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous on a entendu un c'est
la grogne des élus qui dénoncent un
grand bazar sur le terrain martine aubry
la maire de lille qu'on a écouté il ya
quelques secondes demande au
gouvernement de dire la vérité sur ce
manque de vaccins cette pénurie le
gouvernement n'est pas clair on nous
mentirait pierre laurent s'est pas que
le gouvernement augmente mais je pense
qu'il manque de transparence et sur les
difficultés rencontrées sur la situation
réelle et depuis le début mais ça dure
depuis des mois
il associe très peu ou quasiment pas les
élus locaux qui à chaque fois se
retrouvent dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles avec une forte
demande de la population et sans avoir
les moyens d'y répondre
qui a effectivement beaucoup
d'inquiétude mais je pense qu'il faut
mettre le doigt sur le vrai problème
nous sommes désarmés industriellement
nous sommes dépendants industriellement
et ça depuis depuis longtemps donc
aujourd'hui on voit bien que selon qu un
finder va nous livrer vite rapidement ou
pas eh bien ça a des conséquences très
importantes sur la suite
en même temps on sait depuis le début
qu'on n'aura pas assez de vaccins pour
vacciner rapidement tout le monde mais
raison de plus pour dire les choses les
mettre sur la table
associer tout le monde et ce n'est pas
ce qui n'est fait ce qui est fait donc
évidemment ça crée un sentiment de
mauvaise organisation de désorganisation
et ça inquiète la population dans un
moment où vous l'avez dit on a engagé
dans une course de vitesse contre le
contrôle coville bertrand legrand votre
regard de médecins sur ceux entre
guillemets bazar enfin d'ailleurs est ce
que vous êtes vous d'accord avec ce
diagnostic manifestement c'est un petit
peu compliqué sur sur le terrain on est
trop sévère ça va s'améliorer dans les
prochains jours selon vous non je
partage le diagnostic
en réalité on a un problème de
transparence qui est majeure on nous a
dit qu'il y avait eu cinq cent mille
doses par semaine qui avaient été livrés
donc on devrait être à un million cinq
cent mille doses en stock en ce moment
et on en a injecté à à peine entre 200
et 300 fin j'ai pas les derniers juste
les derniers chiffres du jour peut-être
400 et on voit bien que tous les centres
sont restreints très fortement en nombre
de doses donc en fait on nous a
mobilisés parce que c'est ce qu'on ne
comprend pas un moi personnellement
depuis deux semaines je suis sur le pont
pour transformer mon cabinet en centre
de vaccination j'ai d'abord dans un
premier temps au rang d'une première
copie ou qui était trop modeste
on m'a demandé de tripler le nombre de
personnes à vacciner et au bout de deux
semaines même pas quelques jours après
m'avoir dit que c'était pas assez on me
dit bah non on va pas l'ouvrir tout
court parce qu'on n'a pas des doses et
on se rend compte que les doses qui
étaient promises ne sont pas arrivés sur
le territoire et celles qui ont été
annoncées ne sont manifestement ni dans
les congélateurs n'y prête à être
injectés donc on n'a clairement pas les
doses ou alors elles ne sont pas
délivrés et donc on est pour cacher
cette espèce de deux problématiques
on va essayer de faire une file
d'engorgement où on va dire on élargit
la vaccination mais comme on n'a pas les
doses du coup tout le monde va
s'engorger dessus et après on dira c'est
la faute de ceux qui injecte ils sont
pas disponibles est pas capable
d'injecter et on voit bien le piège
politique qui se referme sur les
médecins et sur les médecins
généralistes notamment
on nous a pas fourni d'ozon nous
demander d'investir dans nos cabinets
pour se mettre en ordre de bataille et
au final l'hospital au centrisme et les
fonctionnaires vont permettre de garder
un silence total sur le nombre de doses
il faut une transparence parfaite sur le
nombre de doses qui ont été livrés et
quand elles seront livrés parce que
manifestement nous aurons le bon nombre
de doses mais probablement pas en
janvier pierre laurent il ya deux idées
que nous propose bertrand legrand les
doses sont elles sur le territoire si
oui ou non
où sont-elles et pourquoi ne sont elles
pas approvisionnée ou alors elles ne
sont tout simplement pas sur le
territoire parce qu'il y a un problème
avec l'union européenne
des pays alors certes qui paient plus
cher israël les états unis qui ont
davantage de vaccins que les pays de
l'union européenne non mais probablement
qu'on cumule ou cumuler les problèmes il
ya un problème
enfin il faudrait y voir plus clair mais
il ya très probablement un problème
d'approvisionnement et on est et je le
répète extrêmement dépendants parce que
bon on n'en parle pas assez mais on a
quand même un très grand groupe
pharmaceutique sanofi qui est pour le
moment semble-t-il complètement hors les
clous en tout cas qui n'est pas au
rendez vous un star aujourd'hui qui a
supprimé des postes aujourd'hui en
nombre chez sanofi aujourd'hui donc on
se désarme industriellement de ce côté
là et on reprend pas la main mais ça
fait des années que ça dure sur la
politique industrielle du médicament en
france au contraire mais il ya aussi
probablement des problèmes logistiques
l'état à tous les niveaux s'est
affaiblie visiblement la logistique ne
fonctionne très mal et on fait appel
alors une fois on fait appel aux
collectivités locales ou à d'autres mais
tout ça sans une organisation
manifestement optimale et je le répète
on n'associe pas assez les premiers
intéressés donc on leur demande de se
mobiliser mais sans les associer à la
construction la stratégie vaccinale
donc tout ça ne fonctionne pas mais je
répète qu on a eu un débat au parlement
en décembre sur la stratégie vaccinale
le gouvernement est venu devant le
parlement
toutes ces questions sans aucune
exception ont été posées par nous et par
d'autres et le gouvernement nous a dit
il n'y a pas de problème on maîtrise
tout donc là c'est pas possible de se
retrouver dans cette situation parce que
ça fait la troisième fois depuis le
début hugo vide qu'on est face à un
gouvernement qui nous dit on va
maîtriser la situation et qu'ils la
maîtrisent pas du tout donc à quelque
chose qui va pas dans la conduite des
affaires
il faut changer aussi la mode de
gouvernance de l'eau
la crise dans son ensemble pour
permettre de résoudre ces problèmes
d'après le grand on le constate en tout
cas dans les études d'opinion de plus en
plus de français souhaitent se faire
vacciner 1 52% +14 points par rapport au
week-end dernier comment réagissent vos
patients justement quand vous leur dites
eh bien nous on n'a pas assez de doses
ça se passe comment sur le terrain dans
votre cabinet par exemple sur le terrain
nous jusqu'à ya encore quarante huit
heures on devait ouvrir un centre que un
centre de vaccination qui permettrait de
faire entre 1200 et 3400 vaccinations
par jour dans un cabinet de deux
médecins généralistes 4 administratif
une assistante donc jusqu'à ya 48 heures
on a expliqué aux gens pourquoi on
réorganiser les choses de manière à ce
que ça puisse fonctionner et qu'on soit
efficace et non pas à mettre 10 médecins
pour faire 300 vaccins et donc du coup
les mes patients s'attendent à ce que
j'ai des doses pour le faire puisque
c'est ce qu'a d'efficace la
problématique c'est que on ne me livre
pas ses doses tout simplement
donc je n'ai pas de doses mais rassurez
vous il ya eu 30 doses de vivre est pas
très loin à côté de chez moi à l'hôpital
et une grille files d'attentes qui fait
émerger de plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui du coup voulait faire le
vaccin c'est ça le problème si vous
voulez il ya un moment donné ou si on
donne des doses à des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à les injecter en masse
et que on interdit ceux qui peuvent les
injectées en masse de les injecter il
faut bien y avoir une raison c'est qu'on
a pas là on n'a pas le chou qui faire
alors entre polémique du jour celle sur
les masques le haut conseil de sécurité
un public recommande maintenant de ne
plus utiliser de masque en tissu et la
distanciation sociale qui passa à 2 m le
port du masque en extérieur ça devait
théoriquement freiner l'épidémie en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on nous a dit
les français s'interrogent grandement
masse tissu masques chirurgicaux ça a
servi à quelque chose pierre laurent où
on navigue à vue et c'est bien normal
quelle est votre lecture de cette
confusion régnant d'abord sais pas c'est
pas moi qui devrait répondre à cette
question là c'est d'abord des médecins
qui doivent apporter ce type de réponse
et et nous les responsables politiques
les écouter et probablement les écouter
davantage pour prendre les bonnes
décisions
on y semble qu'il ya tout un tas de
recommandations médicales qui sont plus
ou moins écoutés et parfois assez mal
écouté par le gouvernement ce qui
conduit à des variations dont il peut y
avoir des évolutions dans la stratégie
sanitaire parce qu'on apprend des choses
au fur et à mesure sur les modes de
contagion mais le problème c'est que
dans le dispositif qu'on a actuellement
ni les parlementaires ni les élus locaux
et ni on l'entend avec monsieur avec le
médecin qui était avec nous ni les
médecins qui sont sur le terrain et
d'autres qui nous le disent à l'hôpital
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent qu'ils
ne sont pas écoutés pas associée donc au
bout d'un moment je crois que il faut je
le répète il faut revoir la manière dont
on conçoit tout ça sur les masques moi
si on me disait hier il faut une
distance de temps on me dit aujourd'hui
il en faut une impôts plus grande
vous savez les gens d'une manière
générale contrairement à ce qu'on a dit
parfois sont dans l'ensemble extrêmement
extrêmement discipliné il essaye de
suivre les consignes qui leur sont
données il essaye de les comprendre
c'est pas toujours très facile parce que
ça pèse aussi sur le moral de tout le
monde mais les gens lave pourquoi est ce
qu'il ya un problème avec les vaccins
parce que le gouvernement a dit on
vaccine tous et au camp plus de 75 ans
et tous les plus fragiles donc les gens
demandent à être vaccinés c'est bien
normal puisque c'est le gouvernement qui
a donné le signal de cette vaccination
le problème c'est que les vaccins sont
pas au rendez vous bertrand legrand le
mot de la fin sur cette affaire de matt
cain
on sait qu'en bavière ils sont passés ou
ffp2 obligatoire on s'est trompé là
encore de stratégie
quelle est votre réaction je vais rester
relativement constant j'avais publié une
vidéo en mars qui expliquer la
différence entre un masque ffp2 et un
masque chirurgical j'avais dénoncé en
mars qu'il fallait mettre des masques
ffp2 qu'il fallait commander des masques
ffp2 je n'avais pas imaginé qu'on ose
même faire des masques en tissu bon là
on l'a quand même fait faute de mieux
c'était moins pire qu'autre chose ce
qu'elle est incroyable c'est de se dire
que pendant tous ces mois où on a été
livré des masques chirurgicaux et des
masques ffp2 on n'est pas réussi à
passer outre cette espèce de vision
politique de dire à des gens qui avaient
travaillé comme féfé la couture pour ses
masques en tissu que non effectivement
scientifiquement parlant il valait mieux
quand même un chirurgicale qu'un masque
en tissu et qui valait mieux un ffp2
plutôt qu'un masque chirurgical
mais ça c'est une question de courage
politique et puis de stock mais
manifestement giraud payet comprendre
grand chose en politique
vous n'êtes pas le seul merci c'est une
bertrand de grands verres si pierre
laurent d'avoir été avec nous restez
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
partirons aux états unis
la capitale washington est quadrillée
par l'armée à deux jours de
l'investiture de joe biden un climat
d'inquiétude règne dans la capitale et
puis direction la russie alexeï navalni
et placé en détention jusqu'au 15
février les opposants politiques avaient
été arrêtés hier soir à moscou à sa
descente d'avion
motif avoir violé les conditions d'une
peine de prison avec sursis
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pierre gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout en questionnant
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le monde donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent pour françois vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pierre gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout en questionnant
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le monde donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france à deux
jours de l'investiture de joe biden la
capitale est quadrillée par les forces
de l'ordre et la garde nationale
washington ville figée en attendant le
passage de témoin ce mercredi et
l'absence du président sortant donald
trump qu'on retrouve sur place notre
reporter thomas bonnet bonsoir
thomas bonjour pour vous à deux jours de
l'investiture de joe biden la capitale
des états unis continuent de se
barricader
oui stéphanie et on est devant un point
de contrôle comme il y en a des dizaines
d'autres ici à washington pour pouvoir
aller dans la zone qui se trouve
derrière moi il faut montrer patte
blanche montrer qu'on a une
accréditation pour pouvoir approcher des
bâtiments officiels puisque on est ici à
quelques centaines de mètres de la
maison blanche
ces dispositifs comme celui là il y en a
absolument à tous les coins de rues ici
à washington avec des forces de police
et des forces armées qui ont été
déployés si bien que les rues de la
capitale fédérale sont rythmées par les
bruits des sirènes de police et dès
l'entrée de la ville on peut déjà voir
des camions militaires avec des soldats
en armes
si bien qu'on a l'impression d'arriver
dans une ville en état de siège les
autorités recommandent aux habitants de
ne pas venir dans le centre-ville de
washington ces prochains jours et le
résultat c'est qu'il n'y a quasiment
personne dans les rues de la capitale
fédérale qui ressemble de plus en plus à
une ville fantôme les autorités sont
particulièrement à cran et je voulais
vous donner une illustration de ce
niveau d' alerte ce matin les accès au
bâtiment du capitole ont été restreints
pendant plusieurs minutes suite à une
fumée qui s'échappait d'un endroit pas
très éloigné du capitole il s'agissait
en fait d'un incendie mineur qui avait
lieu en extérieur et que les pompiers de
washington ont rapidement éteint mais
voilà c'est pour donner une illustration
du niveau d' alerte ce qui règne ici
parmi les autorités de washington
thomas que redoute ont concrètement pour
justifier ce déploiement de force
évidemment la raison principale de ce
dispositif de sécurité c'est la crainte
de voir se reproduire les mêmes images
que lors de la manifestation du 6
janvier dernier qui avait rassemblé des
milliers de supporters de donald trump
et on se rappelle certains verts réussi
à pénétrer à l'intérieur du capitole le
lieu même où doit prêter serment joe
biden mercredi le fbi a dit craindre des
manifestations violentes avec des
individus potentiellement armé que ce
soit ici à washington ou dans les autres
états américains aucun incident majeur
pour l'heure n'était à signaler il n'y a
pas eu ce week-end de grosse
manifestation de supporters de donald
trump et j'ai pour ma part discuter avec
des partisans du président sortant qui
m'ont expliqué qu'ils n'avaient
absolument aucune intention de se rendre
à washington ces prochains jours et que
nous toute façon le dispositif de
sécurité est telle qu'ils l'ont bien
compris qu'il était impossible
d'organiser la moindre manifestation ici
alors malgré ton thomas ce sont plus de
25 mille membres de la garde nationale
qui seront présents mercredi
oui étant donné que parmi les supporters
de donald trump et de donald trump
pardon il ya des personnes qui ont des
liens avec l'armée que ce soit parce que
ce sont des anciens soldats ou parce
qu'ils sont de la famille de soldats en
ce moment l'administration militaire est
en train de procéder à des vérifications
pour s'assurer que les membres de la
garde nationale ne soient pas tentés de
participer à une opération violente le
20 janvier prochain écoutez les
précisions du ministre des armées
nous devons être conscients de cela et
nous devons mettre en place tous les
mécanismes pour examiner minutieusement
ces hommes et ces femmes qui
soutiendrait des opérations comme cela
nous sommes continuellement en train de
procéder à ces vérifications
une deuxième une troisième fois pour
chacun des individus assigné à cette
opération
vous l'aurez compris les autorités font
preuve d'une d'une précaution extrême
dans la préparation de cet événement qui
on le rappelle n'aura rien à voir avec
les passations de pouvoir qu'on a pu
connaître dans les années précédentes en
raison de la pandémie d'une part et puis
donc à cause de ce contexte sécuritaire
le public sera fortement réduit avec
notamment des interventions en
visioconférence et surtout l'absence du
président sortant donald trump qui
n'assistera pas à l'investiture de joe
biden donald trump devrait quitter la
maison blanche mercredi matin pour se
rendre dans sa maison en floride
merci thomas bonnin en direct donc de
washington et thomas vient de nous
l'expliquer les autorités sont en alerte
parce que des milliers de manifestants
pro trom commencent à se rassembler
devant les capitales des états il
dénonce toujours une élection volée ont
fait le point en images
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
surtout à droite disait de ne pas aller
au capitole parce qu'il croyait qu'il
pourrait y avoir des attaques violentes
de la gauche ou après les émeutes du
capitole il ne voulait pas être perçu
comme violent c'est pourquoi beaucoup ne
sont pas là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est de l'intimidation
j'ai servi dans l'armée et tout ce
bordel je n'ai pas peur mais c'est de
l'intimidation
quid de la politique étrangère de la
nouvelle administration avec notamment
la chine
avant de quitter le pouvoir le
secrétaire d'état américain à multiplier
les sorties à l'international mike
pompéo s'est montré très critique envers
cuba l'iran le yémen et la chine donc
tout récemment avec des déclarations via
les réseaux sociaux
wally bennani une trentaine de tweets
dirigés à l'encontre de l' empire du
milieu
ce samedi 16 et dimanche 17 janvier
mike pompéo s'est montrée limpides quant
à ses relations avec le parti communiste
chinois
l'administration trump a mis fin à des
décennies d'apaisement et de politique
d'engagement malavisé envers le parti
communiste chinois
nous ne pouvons plus ignorer les
différences politiques et idéologiques
entre les etats-unis et la république
populaire de chine entre la liberté la
tyrannie un véritable tir groupé de la
part du secrétaire d'état américain
bras droit de donald trump depuis 2018
mike pompéo évoque chaque aspect des
relations sino-américaines des quatre
dernières années des relations
détériorées en l'espace d'un an
ma relation avec le président chiite est
extraordinaire il est pour la chine
je suis pour les états unis mais à part
cela nous nous aimons signature d'un
accord quelques jours plus tôt à la
maison blanche qui suspend la guerre
commerciale entamée deux ans plus tôt
baisse des droits de douane sur les
produits chinois achats de produits
américains pour 200 milliards de dollars
au cours des deux prochaines années
un processus d'apaisement miné par un
virus venu de chine le gouvernement
chinois
ouvert aujourd'hui à toute enquête virus
devone le parti communiste chinois la
dissimuler le parti communiste chinois a
fait disparaître les médecins qui
savaient le parti communiste chinois
refuse toujours de laisser entre le
monde pour voir ce qu'il a fait le parti
communiste chinois a menti sur l'origine
du virus
la chine se conformera strictement aux
réglementations et exigences en matière
de prévention des épidémies
et fournira le soutien et les facilités
nécessaires pour que les experts de l'om
s puis se rendre en chine et mener à
bien la coopération internationale en
matière de traçabilité une question de
passes d'armes ces derniers mois sur
plusieurs sujets et sur fond de pandémie
mondiale
en pleine campagne présidentielle donald
trump et son équipe ont davantage haussé
le ton vis-à-vis de la chine
espionnage entreprises chinoises placé
sur une liste noire lois sécuritaires
imposées par pékin hong kong décrié sans
oublier le cas épineux de taïwan mike
pompéo a annoncé la levée des
restrictions imposées aux responsables
américains dans leurs contacts avec
leurs homologues taïwanais
tout le monde y va de la chine s'oppose
fermement à toute forme des changes
officielles entre les états unis et
taiwan la chine continuera à prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
sauvegarder résolument sa souveraineté
et ses intérêts en matière de sécurité
certains hommes politiques américains
paieront inévitablement un lourd tribut
pour leurs déclarations et leurs actions
erronée seule l'audi a1 esprit de
coopération gagnant-gagnant dans
l'intérêt fondamental des deux peuples
déclaration de félicitations fin
novembre du président chinois qui espère
désormais de meilleures relations avec
le président élu joe biden lors d'un
débat présidentiel
ce dernier avait qualifié seeding pin
deux voyous l'allemagne condamne cet
après-midi l'arrestation je cite
arbitraire des l'excellent navalni outre
berlin paris bruxelles et washington
demande également sa libération
immédiate les opposants politiques
arrêtés hier soir à moscou à sa descente
d'avion a été placée tout à l'heure en
détention jusqu'au 15 février
motif avoir violé les conditions d'une
peine de prison avec sursis
juste après cette décision une vidéo
filmée dans la salle d'audience a été
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux dans
laquelle elle excelle navalni apple
amène
festi dans la rue la correspondance en
russie d'antoine clé sergueï lavrov à
l'occasion de sa conférence de presse
annuelle a été interrogé à plusieurs
reprises par des journalistes sur la
sphère navalni à la lumière des
événements d'hier
pour le ministre russe tout le bruit à
l'international autour de cette affaire
n'a pas lieu d'être et il faut laisser
la justice faire son travail
dans l'autre cas de navalni il y ait une
résonance internationale qui je pense
est artificielle et qui est tout à fait
injustifiée tout ce qui se produit ici
au tour de na vallier de son retour son
arrestation
cela relève de décisions des services de
justice et de police
il ya un service fédéral qui est celui
de l'exécution des peines qui a énoncé
sa troupe de fait congrès et qui a
expliqué pourquoi ces réclamations à son
égard ont été donc il n'ya pas de
déclarations possibles du ministère des
affaires étrangères ici à simplement le
respect des lois de la fédération de
russie
il ne reste pas moins que l'arrestation
de l'opposant russe quasiment à sa
descente de l'avion a suscité de
nombreux commentaires indignés parmi les
responsables politiques occidentaux la
france a pris connaissance avec une très
forte préoccupation de l'arrestation en
russie de monsieur alexeï navalni elle
suit avec ses partenaires européens sa
situation avec la plus grande vigilance
et appellent à sa libération immédiate
profondément troublé par la décision de
la russie d'arrêter alexeï navalni et
dirigeants politiques confiant ne
craignent pas les voies concurrentes ni
ne voient la nécessité de commettre des
violences ou de détenir à tort des
opposants politiques
je condamne la détention d' alexeï
navalni par les autorités russes
ils doivent le libérer immédiatement et
assurer sa sécurité
la détention d'opposants politiques va à
l'encontre des engagements
internationaux de la russie après son
rétablissement alexeï navalni a pris la
décision consciente de retourner en
russie
parce qu'ils y voient sa maison
personnelle et politique le fait qu'il a
été arrêté par les autorités russes dès
son arrivée est totalement
incompréhensible
il est consternant alexeï navalni
victime d'un crime méprisable et étaient
détenus par les autorités russes
il doit être immédiatement libérés
plutôt que de persécuter monsieur
navalni la russie devrait expliquer
comment une arme chimique a été utilisée
sur le sol russe elle la détention
d'alexei navalni à son arrivée à moscou
est inacceptable j'appelle les autorités
russes à le libérer immédiatement le
principal intéressé s'est lui aussi
exprimé
il s'insurge contre le traitement
judiciaire qui lui est réservé en
dénonçant l'illégalité de la procédure
en cours
il est même allé plus loin en demandant
aux gens à ses soutiens de descendre
dans la rue pour faire pression sur le
pouvoir
c'est le facteur principal le plus
important c'est l'essence même de la
politique
donc n'ayez pas peur sortez dans la rue
ne sortez pas pour moi sortez pour vous
et pour votre avenir à l'heure actuelle
à l'excès lavagne est donc en détention
pour une durée de 30 jours dans
l'attenté de son jugement
lors de cette audience un juge devra
statuer sur la violation de son contrôle
judiciaire l'opposant russe devait en
effet respecter les conditions d'une
période probatoire qui courait jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2020 alors qu'il
terminait sa convalescence en allemagne
il n'avait plus de fait répondre aux
obligations de son contrôle judiciaire
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales dont soir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alexeï navalni qui a donc souhaité
rentrer en russie sachant il se ferait
arrêter
quels objectifs poursuite il selon vous
et bien en effet il va être sur le
terrain et le agir sur la tille au
théâtre politique russe et puis navalni
gêne il a 44 ans je pense qu'il sera tj
à long terme sa stratégie à long terme
c'est en effet 2
d'augmenter sa notoriété en russie
actuellement il en ces terres une
certaine notoriété à moscou il avait
d'ailleurs surpris tout le monde en 2013
lorsqu'il avait fait 27 % des voix à
l'élection municipale pour l'élection du
maire et dans les grandes villes il a
une certaine notoriété mais globalement
en russie on trouve je crois d'après les
sondages un frein pour cent des russes
qui savent exactement qui il est et qui
approuve plus ou moins sa démarche
donc je pense qu'il a le temps alors il
va agir naturellement lors des
différentes échéances politiques comme
il l'a déjà fait il a déjà fait pour les
essais an des élections régionales en
appelant les électeurs à voter pour le
candidat le mieux placé mais contre le
candidat de russie unie et il fera
probablement la même chose pour les
élections législatives du mois de
septembre prochain
mais encore une fois il a le temps donc
il se positionne pour plus tard pensant
que il y aura bien un jour finalement où
il y aura une relève politique et où la
classe politique qui est actuellement au
pouvoir
cédera la place à une génération plus
jeune alors que signifie une détention
d'une durée de quatre semaines pour lui
voilà je crois que c'est le tarif
puisque en réalité il y avait en effet
une demande de l'administration qui est
chargé de l'exécution des peines et
cette demande reprocher à monsieur
davani de ne pas avoir pointé à un
commissariat de moscou le 30 novembre
dernier pour tout le monde savait qu'il
était en train de se faire soigner à
berlin et qui ne pouvaient pas être dans
ce commissariat
vous trouvez ça fait rien
l'administration chargée de la gestion
des peines a demandé au juge de
prononcer cette peine 2
quatre semaines de prison en attendant
qu'un juge statue au fond je crois que
c'est le début d'un nouveau d'une
nouvelle période de harcèlement
judiciaire à l'égard de navalni il est
avocat donc il connaît ça depuis depuis
longtemps et il joue avec d'ailleurs ses
propres avocats
avec la législation russe pour alterner
les périodes disons de liberté sous
surveillance et des périodes de ses
jours en prison
plusieurs pays condamnant cette
arrestation quelles peuvent être les
conséquences au niveau international oui
alors bien sûr la chine ne condamne pas
et d'une manière générale l'ensemble des
pays d'asie ne se prononce pas les pays
d'afrique non plus tous considèrent que
ceci est une affaire purement intérieure
à la russie en revanche les occidentaux
ont fait d'alexa une avanie une sorte de
symbole
une sorte de symbole de l'opposition
politique en russie
il a en effet un abord très très
médiatique et il a réussi à convaincre
les occidentaux qu'il était le véritable
représentant de l'opposition systémique
en russie et par conséquent bien les
pays européens ont condamné ont demandé
sa libération immédiate
les etats unis également et ce procès
sujet sera sans doute évoqué lors du
conseil européen du 21 janvier donc très
prochainement en visioconférence et
certains pays peut-être demanderont de
nouvelles sanctions il n'est pas sûr que
il y est
un consensus pour décider de nouvelles
sanctions
certaines sanctions avaient déjà été
votée et après tout la détention qui a
été infligé à monsieur navalni nez
j'allais dire n'est que de quatre
semaines c'est déjà beaucoup mais je
pense que l'union européenne va plutôt
pesé pour qu'ils soient libérés le plus
tôt possible
quel avenir selon vous pour alexeï
navalni en russie comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
joue à long terme et la première
question c'est de savoir s'il va gagner
son pari le pari qu'il a fait en
revenant hier à moscou à savoir de
gagner en notoriété et de gagner
finalement dans l'opinion publique
c'est loin d'être certain parce que en
effet elle est certainement très
populaire chez les gens qui naviguent
sur les réseaux sociaux dans les grandes
villes mais lee est à peu près inconnu
ailleurs en russie est d'une autre un
autre un autre aspect c'est que
aujourd'hui la population russe est
surtout préoccupé par la dégradation de
la situation économique de la situation
sociale et la situation sanitaire
or sur ces projets de fond monsieur la
vanille ne s'exprime pas merci et qu'il
attend les prochaines élections pour
pouvoir agir ou merci claude blanche
raison d'avoir été avec nous avoir
apporté votre analyse et notre
correspondant moscou nous disait tout à
l'heure sergueï lavrov s'est donc
exprimé sur ce dossier n'est bonne ni
rejetant les critiques il est également
revenu aujourd'hui sur la situation sur
un autre sujet l'ukraine le chef de la
diplomatie russe qui évoque des avancées
limiter dans les négociations traité
lors des réunions dites au format
normandie autrement dit entre paris
berlin kiev et moscou a à cette carte
des routes qui les allemands les
français ont pesé à d'élaborer il ya
trois ou quatre ans maintenant cette
idée
nos jours de nouveau à l'époque il
s'agissait de faire synchroniser la
progression de ce projet de sécurité et
la coopération des forces
l'éloignement des armements lourds à le
fonctionnement dépend des contrôles de
passage pour laisser pour les verts la
circulation civile et et les mesures de
règlement politique
l'amnistié des élections à les
négociations sur le statut mais n'a pas
su le faire parce que la partie
ukrainienne a s'est opposé à cette
progression parallèle en exigeant les
résolutions de toutes les questions
sécuritaires avant d'entamer les
questions de règlement politique
dans le reste de l'actualité en ouganda
la situation politique est toujours
tendue la demeure du leader de
l'opposition ougandaise est toujours
encerclés par des soldats et la police
bobines réclame à la levée de son
assignation à résidence l'opposant avait
dénoncé des fraudes dans le scrutin qui
a consacré la victoire pour un sixième
mandat
ayo ali museveni francs soit risqué
beach devant le siège de bobby wine le
ballet des forces de sécurité est
incessant depuis vendredi le leader de
l'opposition ne peut plus sortir de chez
lui
et si le pouvoir dit vouloir assurer sa
sécurité
le parti de bobby wine là nous affirme
qu'il est assigné à résidence
we demand nous exigeons la libération
immédiate et inconditionnelle de notre
chef et sa déclaration immédiate en tant
que président de la république
jument élus car nous savons qu'il a
gagné l'ancien chanteur de ragga
conteste les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle donnant la victoire à
lyon et rim ou cv ni pour un sixième
mandat
bobby wine assure que le scrutin est
entaché de fraudes des fraudes
constatées par les observateurs
indépendants dont le travail a été rendu
impossible par une coupure d'internet
qui dure depuis mercredi veille du jour
de vote
une coupure préventive selon le
gouvernement afin d'éviter les des
informations risquant de fragiliser
l'intégrité du processus électoral et
des résultats des résultats en toute
transparence pour le président yoweri
museveni
je pense que cela peut s'avérer être
l'élection la plus transparente depuis
1972 6e tour ce net succès tout pour un
peu cher depuis 1962 nous avons eu un
problème de gens voulant triché dans les
élections c'est le problème chronique de
l'ouganda à l'aube le mot biogaz au
début du mois
bobby wine avait déposé plainte contre
le président nos cv ni à la cour pénale
internationale pour crimes contre
l'humanité pour violations des droits
humains et des libertés civiles des
violations toujours en cours selon le
parti du leader de l'opposition
plusieurs de ses membres déclarant ces
derniers jours avoir été arrêté et
frappé par les forces de sécurité
restent avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la campagne
vaccinale française elle accélère mais
pourrait bien se heurter m
pénurie de doses alors comme s'en
inquiète d'ailleurs les élus et puis
nous parlerons de l'europe
les tours de vis sanitaires se
poursuivent comme en allemagne ou en
italie alors que les menaces du variant
se fait de plus en plus pressante
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ce salarié écrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent et
homme d'état
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers vous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir avec comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
sur les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans
nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
sa deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 18 janvier
la vaccination ouverte à plus de 6
millions de français depuis aujourd'hui
ici la population sans moins réticentes
les élus eux s'inquiètent du faible
nombre de doses reçues et le temps
presse face aux variants notamment
britannique qui deviendrait dominant en
france entre fin février et mi mars
selon l'inserm le haut conseil de santé
publique recommande de ne plus utiliser
de masque en tissu et de garder deux
mètres de distance pour faire face à
cette nouvelle menace
en europe aussi tout s'accélère les
l'instruction comme les vaccinations
l'allemagne va renforcer demain encore
un peu plus les règles de confinement la
bavière elle a décidé d'imposer le port
du masque ffp2 dans les transports en
commun et les commerces depuis
aujourd'hui en italie lombardie sicile
et tyrol du sud ça passe en zone rouge
le pays a dépassé le million de
personnes vaccinées
[Musique]
la charte des principes de l'islam
adopté par le conseil français du culte
musulman emmanuel macron salut à un
engagement clair net et précis même si
trois fédérations n'ont pas encore signé
le texte
une annonce qui intervient alors que le
projet doit contre les séparatistes mais
fait son entrée aujourd'hui en
commission des lois à l'assemblée la
question du voile divise déjà la
majorité le gouvernement israélien pour
la construction de près de 800 logements
dans des colonies de cisjordanie occupée
londres se dit gravement préoccupé et
rappelle que ces colonies sont illégales
au droit au regard du droit
international
cette décision intervient en pleine
campagne électorale pour les élections
législatives du mois de mars
nouvelle étape à dans la campagne de
vaccination un mec sain désormais
disponible aux personnes âgées de 75 ans
vivant seul mais aussi aux français
porteurs de comorbidité de maladie les
exposant à des risques particulièrement
grave du coc vide
le gouvernement appelle à de la patience
avec l'ambition d'un million de
vaccinations réaliser d'ici la fin
janvier
walid d'ennemis un déplacement tout
sourire
le ministre de la santé ravi de revenir
sur c'était un gros boulot dès les beaux
jours
merci pour le chu de grenoble là où il a
exercé en qualité de neurologue comme un
petit point dans le coeur parce que ça
me dit c'est quand même pas seulement un
retour aux sources mais un déplacement
scruté pour annoncer une étape décisive
dans une campagne de vaccination qui
concerne désormais plus de 6 millions de
français
seniors et personnes présentant des
pathologies à haut risque sont ciblés
partout en france plus de 800 centres de
vaccination instar de ce centre
grenoblois se sont mis en place
ils se sont mis en place grâce à la
mobilisation extraordinaire je le dis
des soignants des hôpitaux des soignants
de ville mais également des pompiers de
la sécurité civile avec un rôle très
important joué par les collectivités
qu'ils agissent des maires des
départements ou des régions des
félicitations mais une démarche
vaccinale qui fait débat aujourd'hui une
personne âgée de plus de 75 ans et
vivant seul peut donc se rendre sur le
site ww point sante.fr ou téléphoner
pour prendre rendez vous
impressions on s'adresse quand même dans
la première partie à une personne à une
population pardon de deux personnes
âgées qui peu moins l'habitude de d
internet et des choses comme ça mais il
faut avoir un peu pas de science mais
l'accueil a été formidable
ah c'est mon fils qui m'a prévenu
au rendez vous j'ai été très bien
accueilli cette désorganisation se sent
en sécurité
donc il n'ya pas de problème la personne
vaccinée et gardé en observation pendant
15 minutes avant de repartir avec la
date d'un nouveau rendez vous pour le
rappel de vaccination de doses sont
nécessaires pour éradiquer le virus
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude grandit quant
aux ambitions du gouvernement
malheureusement nous allons recevoir
seulement 500 doses par semaine ce qui
nous permettra de vacciner uniquement 80
personnes par jour au lieu de 1000 à ce
rythme il nous faudra plusieurs mois
pour vacciner toute la population âgée
de plus de 75 heures du 15e c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous lançons un
appel à l'état
ouverture ce matin d'un centre de
vaccination municipale à la salle des
fêtes de fives d'une capacité de madère
de 840 personnes déjà complet pour les
deux prochaines semaines nous pouvons
faire beaucoup plus à condition d'avoir
les vaccins je suis inquiète que le
gouvernement dise la vérité sur le
nombre de vaccins disponibles une
politique de flux tendus que défend
aujourd'hui le ministre de la santé
donc si la question c'est plus je
programme de gens plus aux mêmes données
vaccins au détriment des territoires
voisins
la réponse elle est non il ya une
répartition harmonieuse en fonction de
la population pour pouvoir protéger tous
les français de la même manière et de
manière progressive avec une exception
c'est les territoires dans lesquels le
virus circule le plus un gouvernement
qui annonce entre 2 et 4 millions de
personnes vaccinées d'ici fin février
aujourd'hui selon un dernier sondage
ifop le parisien 54% des français sont
prêts à sauter le pas est le vaccin
français lui est toujours attendu sanofi
qui doit le produire annoncé aux
syndicats que 400 postes dévolus à la
recherche pharmaceutique elle est
bientôt disparaître une déclaration dans
le prolongement de la volonté du géant
pharmaceutique de réduire ses effectifs
sanofi avait annoncé en juin dernier la
suppression de 1700 postes en europe
dont un millier en france
une situation qui inquiète toutefois les
représentants syndicaux distancé dans la
course au vaccin sanofi a divisé par
deux les effectifs de ces chercheurs en
dix ans
et pour en parler mais aussi évoqué la
crise sanitaire en france nous sommes
avec thierry amouroux porte parole du
syndicat des infirmiers syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
plus précisément vont se voir thierry
amougou merci d'être avec nous tout
d'abord même si peut-être que vous ne
connaissez pas le dossier en détail vous
avez peut-être un sentiment une réaction
après ces annonces de suppressions de
postes chez sanofi en pleine pandémie
alors que le laboratoire beaucoup de
retard sur le maxi oui c'est absolument
incroyable c'est à dire que on voit que
rapport aux grands pays la patrie de
pasteur est la seule nation à ne pas
produire un vaccin
aujourd'hui et que sanofi qui a pour le
coup des ratés dans son projet de vaccin
en vient est licencié la moitié de son
service recherche et développement donc
ça inquiète par rapport à à l'avenir et
aux besoins de la france de produire
localement ce qui est nécessaire aux
besoins de santé de sa population
aujourd'hui pour vous c'est une forme
d'aveu d'échec on sait que sanofi tout
même un petit peu à la traîne par
rapport aux autres vaccins avec un
retard de plusieurs mois et un vaccin
qui n'est pas attendu avant au moins six
mois n'est ce pas oui parle d'un vaccin
pour la fin de l'année vous que ça va
peut-être arriver après la bataille
surtout que là on voit qu'ils aient
course contre la montre qui s'engage par
rapport aux variants anglais qui va
augmenter la contamination et donc il
faudrait accélérer la vaccination pour
contrecarrer ce lorient gay vous parler
d'accélération de la vaccination on en
vient d'un autre actualité de la journée
on a vu ses premières réactions
vaccination pour les plus de 75 ans
or et pas les malades à risques avec
voilà il n'y a pas d'autre mot des
galères sur le terrain pour nos élus
clairement aujourd'hui on craint dans
les milieux hospitaliers dont vous
faites partie une pénurie de vaccins
oui clairement c'est à dire que les
premières livraisons sont arrivés le 26
décembre et aujourd'hui on est à un
million six cent cinquante et un mille
doses de vaccin en 23 jours et dans le
même temps on sait qu'il ya un million
de personnes à vacciner en ehpad qui a 5
millions de personnes âgées de plus de
75 ans à vacciner chez eux et 800 me le
malade chronique fragile qu'il faut
vacciner aussi le très rapidement donc 7
millions de personnes et qu'il faut
protéger le plus rapidement possible
dont 14 millions de doses et on n'a reçu
que les millions 600 mille
donc ça c'est première inquiétude
surtout que comme par hasard on apprend
que lusinchi et livre l'europe doit
faire des travaux va ralentir les
livraisons et du mal à comprendre tout
ça c'est bien beau vous faisiez partie
des prioritaire puisque vous êtes
infirmier en soignant vous avez pu vous
faire vacciner sans problème
alors pour ce qui est de mon cas
personnel gilles kovic est toujours des
anticorps donc je préfère que les rares
doses que l'on a soit utilisé pour les
patients un peu fragile mais tous les
palais tous les professionnels de santé
qui le souhaitent arrive à se faire
vacciner a assez rapidement
pour l'instant mais l'inquiétude quand
même c'est également l'utilisation des
doses que l'on a
parce que je vous ai dit qu on l union
600 mille doses mais pour l'instant on
n'en n'a utilisé que un peu moins de 480
milles soit un peu moins de 29 % et
comment vous l'expliquez ça thierry
amouroux est-ce que déjà vous
l'expliquer ben la spécialité française
c'est la technostructure avec eux les
agences régionales de santé
toute la production d'un guide de 45
pages voilà donc on comprend tout de
suite que en france et tout de suite
complique plus compliqué parce qu'il ya
un point le ministre hâtif très très
lourd
là où il faudrait de la souplesse
donc voilà puis les élus de terrain vous
tirez amouroux quel est le moral dans
dans vos rangs on sait qu'une journée
nationale d'action est prévue pour le 21
janvier à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
on imagine que c'est difficile aussi
pour vous d'autant que le variant fait
peur aurélie nul pourrait constituer
la moitié des cas de co vide en france à
la mi février mi mars c'est ce que nous
dit l'inserm vous le craignez ce
variance a atteint encore peut-être plus
votre moral aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr on craint c'est varié
anglais parce que on a vu en angleterre
qui a rapidement dépassé le le sarko
veut d'origine et le problème c'est
qu'il est beaucoup plus contagieux donc
il se diffuse beaucoup plus facilement
ce qui veut dire que il va y avoir
beaucoup plus de personnes d'atteinte et
s'il ya beaucoup plus de personnes
d'atteinte
il ya également beaucoup plus de
personnes qui vont passer par les
urgences qui vont venir à l'hôpital qui
vont devoir être hospitalisée et qui
vont devoir est en réanimation donc même
si le variant n'ai pas pu grave en soi
le fait qu'ils soient plus contaminantes
fille qu'il y aura beaucoup plus de
patients dans les hôpitaux et ça c'est
un peu inquiétant ce pour ça que je dis
qu'il ya vraiment une course contre la
montre en particulier sur les patients
fragiles 7 millions de personnes qui
doivent être vaccinés le plus vite
possible avant que le variant glen ou
des portes quoi donc là une vraie
inquiétude est effectivement le jeudi
prochain milliard il ya un mouvement des
hospitaliers pour dénoncer un peu la
situation
parce que derrière les effets de
communication avec le ministre qui se
déplace sur les hôpitaux en disant ouais
c'est formidable va bien haxhi nation et
c'est donc en même temps le gouvernement
il ferme des lits on est le seul pays du
monde où on ferme des lits en pleine
période épidémique
donc ça c'est un vrai souci parce que
nous mois après mois on voit bien que il
ya moan qui il ya moins de personnel et
alors que la situation
perdure et là risquent de s'aggraver
avec ce vin anglais qui va multiplier
les cas d'hospitalisation
merci en tout cas thierry amouroux à
nous avoir donné votre état d'esprit en
direct sur rt france merci à vous et la
crise sanitaire en europe et en italie
les autorités qui durcissent les mesures
sanitaires avec der confinement locaux
l'épidémie a fait plus de 80 mille morts
et les contaminations ne recule pas aimé
dans certaines villes des restaurateurs
et des habitants décidé de passer outre
félix ul traumatisée par la première
vague de l'épidémie
l'italie tente de maîtriser la seconde
alors la péninsule se recombinent avec
des différences en fonction des régions
trois d'entre elles sont mises sur liste
rouge la lombardie la sicile et leo'o
adige dans ces territoires
les déplacements non justifiées sont
maintenant interdits et les commerces
non essentiels resteront fermés à rome
le confinement est moins stricte mais
les mesures se durcissent alors qu'ils
étaient jusque-là ouvert les bars et les
restaurants n'ont désormais plus le
choix ils doivent se limiter à la vente
à emporter un drame pour ce propriétaire
c'est très difficile pour nous à partir
de demain 28 de nos employés resteront
chez eux sans oublier nos contrats
courts qui eux aussi resteront chez eux
pour nous c'est vraiment très difficile
en ce moment
mais certains ont décidé de désobéir
dans plusieurs régions des restaurateurs
ont défié les autorités aient ouvert le
restaurant parfois soutenues par les
clients les restrictions qu'ils imposent
avec cette soi-disant urgences ne
détruisent tous mexico logiquement et
économiquement donc ce monsieur qui ait
le courage d'ouvrir son restaurant a
besoin d'être soutenue par les gens et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes venus nous
sommes très heureux d'apporter notre
soutien ce restaurateur parce que notre
avis les mesures qui ont été prises tant
pour arrêter la propagation du virus ou
pour la prévenir sont exagérées face à
la fronde les policiers ont patrouillé
et distribuer des amendes
les nouvelles mesures sont en place
jusqu'au 15 février minimum alors que le
pays poursuit sa campagne de vaccination
hier le chiffre d'un million d'italiens
vaccinées étaient dépassées et l'espagne
elle envisage de ramener l'heure du
couvre-feu à 20 heures face à la
progression du coronavirus depuis les
fêtes de fin d'année le pays subit de
plein fouet la troisième vague
épidémique jusque là laissé à la libre
appréciation de chaque région les
horaires du couvre-feu pourrait bien
être harmonisés à partir de ce mercredi
l'espagne qui est passé à la vitesse
supérieure dans sa campagne de
vaccination le pays a commencé hier
administré à des seconds doses du vaccin
présent biotech aux premières immunité
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe emmanueli médecins généralistes
bonsoir philippe-emmanuel dit merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
l'espagne sur un fil comme d'ailleurs la
france
est-ce que clairement se dirige vers un
nouveau confinement chez vous bonsoir
stéphanie de murs rue les nouvelles
mesures sont en discussion actuellement
et rien n'est arrêté
concernant les nouvelles mesures qui
seront prises par le gouvernement car
comme vous l'avez dit jusqu'à maintenant
une délégation a été donnée aux
différentes communautés autonomes pour
prendre des décisions et une révision de
la loi sur l'état d'alerté nécessaire si
l'on veut prendre des décisions au
niveau national l'espagne qui a passé en
tout cas la seconde vague sans
confinement à domicile comme l'a rappelé
le ministre de la santé ça dit quoi
eh bien ça dit qu' il y à il y à
d'autres voies que le confinement
généralisée des mesures tout restrictive
moi je suis bien placé pour l'observer
sur barcelone où finalement les
l'ouverture des restaurants a été limité
mais autorisé dans des tranches horaires
dits fini avec des taux d'occupation
également défini et aujourd'hui en
catalogne où effectivement on veut dire
que la densité de restaurant est assez
importante
on ne peut pas dire que la catalogne
soit la région où on observe le rebond
le plus important loin de là donc
effectivement on a le sentiment ici en
espagne d'un confinement un peu plus
soft et qui a peut-être trouvé des voies
intermédiaire pour concilier à la fois
le respect de l'activité économique et à
la fois une certaine maîtrise de
l'épidémie ducobu alors mercredi dans
les communautés territoriales et
gouvernement doivent évoquer la
possibilité de rallonger
durée du couvre feu dans le pays à 20
heures c'est une bonne chose selon vous
m'écoutez scac est aujourd'hui en
espagne c'est que dans certaines
communautés autonomes on retrouve des
chiffres de contagiosité qui sont de
l'ordre de 2000 pour cent mille
habitants
bon ok avec parfois des pics même dans
certaines régions autonomes comme l'ex
trama doit à 1300 ce qui est très
important et ce qui peut annoncer
effectivement à nouveau une saturation
des hôpitaux
donc c'est vrai que le gouvernement ne
peut pas rester insensible à ces
nouveaux chiffres et mais ils
privilégient à nouveau finalement la
mesure peut-être la moins restrictif
pour la population et vous voyez
finalement on se limiterait à un
avancement du toqué de kedah du
couvre-feu à 20h contre 18 heures en
france
alors parmi les mesures notamment
attendus en france ce sera mercredi pour
nous les vacances de ski de février qui
concernent des français bien sûr mais
surtout de nombreuses familles qui
vivent de cela en espagne c'est assez
original parce qu'on est remonté marche
mais au prix d'un strict protocole
sanitaire ça fonctionne oui écoutez j'ai
pas de retour vraiment sur les
statistiques liées à l'ouverture des
remontées mécaniques passe comment ce
genre de statistique n'est pas vraiment
disponibles après il faut savoir que
c'est quand même associé ou est ce
qu'ils appellent le périmétre halles
c'est à dire que l'ailé par exemple les
barcelonais n'ont pas accès aux stations
de ski 1 c'est à dire que vraiment c'est
réservé aux gens qui habitent dans les
proximité des stations de ski
la campagne de vaccination à présent en
espagne le pays a commencé à 2013
administrer la deuxième dose près de
1100 milles espagnols ont déjà reçu leur
première injection comment ça se passe
chez vous en espagne on voit qu'en
france est un petit peu laborieux
on craint des pénuries claire de vaccins
c'est le cas en espagne également
alors oui tout à fait parce que
effectivement la mesure de restriction
en termes d'approvisionnement des
vaccins et européennes
ici on est peut-être plus clair qu'en
france puisque le ministre de la santé a
donné un chiffre qui est celui d'une
baisse d'approvisionnement de 50% par
rapport au dos qui était initialement
prévu
donc on sait effectivement que la
vitesse de vaccination va être divisé
par deux à partir de cette semaine
merci philippe à emmanueli médecins
généralistes d'avoir donné un petit peu
la situation le panorama en tout cas de
cette crise sanitaire en espagne et
direction présent la tunisie le
confinement générale s'est achevée
dimanche mais les restrictions comme le
couvre feu sont toujours de rigueur dans
un contexte tendu dix ans après la chute
de ben ali
notre reporter ben hassen chébili à
tunis nous donne plus d'explications
bonsoir bassem après quatre jours de
confinement allégé quelle est la
situation sanitaire sur place longtemps
stéphanie effectivement après quatre
jours de confinement total sur
l'ensemble du territoire le gouvernement
a levé ce confinement total mais un
confinement plus allégée a été mis en
place
les commerces sont ouverts les mosquées
sont ouvertes des écoles et les
universités les collèges du restaurant
terme et jusqu'au 24 janvier prochain la
circulation est plutôt fluide on peut
circuler sans autorisation sur
l'ensemble du territoire les bars les
restaurants ainsi que les cafés
resteront ouverts mais simplement avec
des ventes à emporter donc que possible
de ne rester que réunir dans les cafés
les restaurants et les bars objectif du
gouvernement vraiment contenir cette
deuxième vague du coronavirus dans une
situation assez chaotique il faut dire
en tunisie où cette crise dépasse
complètement les capacités du
gouvernement le ministère de la santé a
même annoncé plus de 5600 16 décès
depuis le début de cette pandémie on
arrive à un chiffre de 17 1723
contaminées qui ont été
c'est par le ministère de la santé la
tunisie n'a toujours pas de vaccin même
si un contrat est établi et cloud files
heures pour une livraison prévue
normalement à partir du mois de mars
mais le gouvernement a demandé à son
ministre des affaires étrangères de
pouvoir développer d'autres relations
avec des pays détenteurs du vaccin afin
de pouvoir se procurer d'autres vaccins
c'était le cas notamment avec la russie
je rencontre avait été organisée il ya
quelques jours avec l'ambassadeur de
russie en tunisie pour pouvoir se
procurer ne se doute ni qu'elle faisait
qui devrait normalement arriver en
tunisie si les négociations aboutissent
entre les deux pays voilà pour le monde
peut le dire sur la situation en vue
sanitaire en tunisie avec des hôpitaux
complètement débordé 100% délire
l'animation occupés alors des
restrictions bassam qui s'ajoute un
contexte d'instabilité politique et de
difficultés économiques on imagine en
contexte tendu en tunisie effectivement
ces familles depuis le début de ce qu'on
signe mans le 14 janvier qui symbolisait
les dix ans de la révolution en tunisie
le gouvernement ait choisi cette date là
pour éviter des rassemblements il a
expliqué qu'il voulait éviter la
propagation massive de ce virus mais les
tunisiens ne l'ont pas pris comme ça ils
se sont sentis priver de cette
célébration célébrer les dijon de la
révolution dans un contexte économique
et sanitaire à catastrophique en tunisie
avec des crises partie zahlé et une
incapacité à s'entendre entre les partis
politiques ce qui fait qu'il ya une
incapacité à mettre en place les
réformes est nécessaire beaucoup de
manifestations ont été organisées des
tensions très palpable entre les forces
de l'ordre
et puis des jeunes ont été relevés
depuis plus de quatre jours ça continue
encore ce soir dans la capitale et dans
d'autres villes sur l'ensemble du pays
le porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur lors d'une allocation a fait
part de plus de six cent trente deux
arrestations et ça c'était que hier soir
des arrestations de jeunes massivement
entre 14 et 25 ans il a déclaré que les
personnes majeures devront comparaître
devant la justice le président de la
république rsa et les lui est descendu
dans la rue la rencontre des jeunes
c'était aujourd'hui dans les alentours
de 18 heures il a déclaré que les jeunes
tunisiens révoltés ne seront jamais
considérés
des voleurs voilà ce que le président a
déclaré pour essayer de calmer cette
tension palpable qui ne semble pas
redescendre plusieurs groupes facebook
ont été créées sur les réseaux sociaux
pour rapper à manifester davantage
contre cette situation économique qui
devient très pénible pour les tunisiens
il n'arrive plus à qu'ils n'arrivent
plus à finir le mois une manifestation
est organisée aujourd'hui en centre
ville de la capitale avec des slogans
hostiles au parti ennahda hostiles au
gouvernement mais principalement au
parti ennahda qui le rend responsable de
la situation catastrophique et
économique du pays
merci ma femme chérie en direct de
tunisie rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du projet de loi
contre les séparatismes et soixante dix
députés de la commission spéciale sur le
texte ont commencé ce lundi son examen
et débat risque d'être intense quelques
1700 amendements ont été déposés
et puis direction les colonies de
cisjordanie occupée le gouvernement
israélien ou la construction de près de
800 logements suscitant notamment la
réprobation de londres
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que des candides
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes et le sang les lames on
les a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état
je pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jours
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a acté
plus mauvaise que beaucoup de nos pays
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir avec comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france 21h30 heure de paris le conseil
français du culte musulman a
formellement approuvé hier soir une
charte des principes de l'islam de
france on y reviendra dans quelques
instants avec notre invité
mais d'abord une annonce qui intervient
alors que le projet de loi contre les
séparatismes fait son entrée aujourd'hui
en commission des lois à l'assemblée un
texte
rebaptisé projet de loi comportant les
principes républicains
quelques 1700 monde ont été déposés la
question du voile parasites déjà les
discussions plus de détails sur place
avec katia technique
tout d'abord une ambiance un peu tendue
on va cause des amendements je
reviendrai plus tard sur ce sujet en
effet comme vous le disiez débute
aujourd'hui l'examen en commission dès
51 article alors initialement ce projet
vise à combattre l'islam radical il a
été débaptisée pour peut-être moins de
polémique alors que contient le projet
en lui-même aujourd'hui et bien par
exemple il renforce encore la neutralité
du service public il réprime plus
fortement les personnes qui ferait
l'apologie du terrorisme
il vise à mieux contrôler les lieux de
culte à mieux contrôler le financement
des associations à combattre le mariage
forcé finalement rien de très polémique
finalement cette controverse viendra des
amendements 1869 déposé alors je vais
parler d'un particulier le port du voile
des filles est proposée par aurore bergé
il a été immédiatement rejetée mais ils
marquent cette scission au sein de la
majorité
donc déjà une ambiance de polémique et
peut-être d'amertume et puis autre
indignation celle des députés les
républicains qui sont extrêmement en
colère que la majorité des amendements
qu'ils ont déposés et bien été rejetée
avant même toute discussion ils s'en
sont plaints organisant aujourd'hui une
conférence de presse spéciale je vous
propose d'écouter à ce sujet damien abad
président du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée j'invite la majorité à
relire le fond de cet article 45 qui dit
très clairement qu'on peut déposer des
amendements qui est un objet direct ou
indirect avec le texte quand on a un
texte sur les principes républicains
quand le coeur du sujet c'est la laïcité
comment refuser un amendement qui
concerne les prisons comment refuser un
amendement qui concerne par exemple
mettre en place
des référents radicalisation dans nos
universités avoir un débat sur le port
du voile
on peut être pourront peut être contre
mais on n'a pas le droit d'escamoter de
tronquer le débat et encore plus quand
c'est pour des raisons politiciennes
parce que la vérité c'est que ce
gouvernement ne veut pas du débat il a
peur du débat sur le séparatisme il
recule parce qu'il sait qu'il est
divisée et que ce en même temps se
transforme en fête en renoncements
permanent c'est ça la réalité c'est ça
que nous contestons et le parlement il
peut pas être l'otage de chicaya au sein
de la majorité parlementaire actuelle
oui c'est une instrumentalisation
politique d'articles 45 c'est bien toute
instrumentalisation politique des débats
à l'assemblée nationale et s'est
totalement inconcevable sur un texte qui
je le rappelle était le dernier texte
important c'est le gouvernement qui le
dit lui même de cette mandature sur une
tête qui est censé nous rassembler sur
le texte sur lequel on doit en tout cas
converger c'est ce ne sont pas des
petits sujets alors autre sujet de
polémique le fait que le sujet passe en
procédure accélérée alors que gérald
darmanin guise terre du ministre de
l'intérieur avait promis que ce ne
serait pas le cas donc voici pour le
contexte et l'ambiance 1 le jour de
l'examen des articles
aujourd'hui on est les dirigeants du
conseil français du culte musulman reçu
ce matin à l'elysée par le président
emmanuel macron et ce au lendemain de la
charbon s'est dotée hier l'islam de
france
le texte affirme la compatibilité de la
foi musulmane avec les principes de la
république dont la laïcité l'égalité
homme-femme et le rejet de
l'instrumentalisation de l'islam à des
fins politiques
ce texte doit encore être examiné à
l'assemblée nationale début février au
boycott des produits français
la charte des principes de l'islam de
france adopté par le conseil français du
culte musulman est un engagement net
clair et précis en faveur de la
république
ce texte marque une étape extrêmement
importante en permettant une
clarification de l'organisation du culte
musulman et pour en parler nous sommes
avec abdallah zekri délégué général du
cfcm conseil français du culte musulman
qui a donc approuvé cette charte
bonsoir abdallah zekri merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
cette charte
emmanuel macron l'a salué comme étant un
engagement d'être clair et précis on
faveur de la république c'est aussi
votre avis c'est un texte qui va être
efficace compte pour lutter contre le
séparatisme
je ne pense pas d'ailleurs le
séparatisme je n'aime pas du tout lors
d'une rencontre avec monsieur dame à la
ministre de l'intérieur
on les avait dire que le mois
séparatiste franchement nous dérange
elle avait pris l'engagement que ça soit
supprimée il a été supprimé
aujourd'hui les journalistes et hommes
politiques et mac séparatisme il ya le
renforcement si vous voulez de la
laïcité mais séparatisme les musulmans
n'ont jamais demandé se parer de l'état
à ce produit le deuxième point là je
suis surpris que j'entendais les
journalistes y compris vous dire que 5
de chardy le conseil national du sida
amd présenter un président qu'elle a été
satisfait et que tout le monde était
d'accord je suis désolé de ce qui a été
rapporté par tous les correspondants qui
était sur place en fait pas de nous qui
ont été douloureux alors il ya peut-être
là il ya peut-être eu à manger vous
allez nous expliquer mais voilà je
tenais à vous le dire c'est ce qui a été
prêté j'écoutais du ps qui fait le
journaliste qui était sur place et a
cinq fédérations qui se sont rendus sur
huit générations à l'elysée les trois
autres n'étaient pas présents et n'ont
pas cédé
cette charte donc il n'y a pas unanimité
d'ailleurs hier lorsqu'elle a visé la
visioconférence entre la fédération il
ya des fédérations qui ont dit
clairement qu'ils ne diraient pas
charger pardonnez-moi pardonnez moi je
retiens excusez moi je tiens à vous
couper parce que la question c'était
voilà emmanuel macron qu'ils sont
félicités salle est une de mes
prochaines questions trois fédérations
qui n'ont pas du tout signé le texte
donc là je vous parlais des manuels
macron qui sont satisfaisantes je ne
parlais pas de tout le monde qu'on soit
bien clair voilà
merci je pense que je pense que monsieur
présent la république avant de se
féliciter
il faut qu'il déclare clairement qui a
pas unanimité sur ces textes parce que
quand tu avais une charge les imams et
que les images en temps je passe sacha
dans la chance effectivement c'était ma
question suivante trois fédérations dont
l'association foi et pratique plutôt
présenté comme ultra rigoriste n'ont pas
signé ce texte c'est monsieur moussaoui
un du cfcm d'ailleurs qu'il a dit aux
journalistes sur place parlant de
quelques petites nuances lui il a parlé
de petits tenir ensemble sur moussaoui
du cfcm dont vous faites partie
quelles sont ces nuances peut-être que
vous n'avez pas la même lecture ce ne
sont pas des petites nuances il ya des
grands désaccords selon vous des cinq
ans je pense pas des petites nuances
parce que s'ils avaient des petites
nuances se serait présenté pour essayer
d expliquer il ya un désaccord sur
beaucoup de sujets et par conséquent les
trois fédérations n'ont pas signé moi je
fais partie de la fédération lorsqu'elle
paris lorsqu'elle paraît pas la signer
mais maintenant les autres fédérations
qui l'ont pas signé elles sont
entièrement libres maintenant elles sont
des raisons c'est qu'elles sont des
raisons mais ils élevés que dans cette
charte la procédure vu que toute femme à
signer et tout ce qui a été dans la
chatte existe déjà par le passé et je
pense que ça ne servait à rien certains
articles
je prends par exemple un cas très simple
lorsqu'on parle d'égalité en vain je ne
sais pas l'islam et les musulmans
ce problème là existent en france parce
que ma prime mc ren le président a nommé
ministre chargé de l'égalité
donc c'était l'égalité c'est pas le fait
également pas du tout et rien d'autre un
autre point aussi je vois qu'à
l'assemblée nationale ils sont pas du
tout d'accord sur ce sujet là moi je dis
qu'il charge concernant le cancer
les premiers intéressés ça va être les
imams et c'est la base qui doit décider
ce n'est pas le sommet alors
effectivement vous faites bien de parler
de lui-même parce que c'est l'un des
points clés de cette charte la création
d'un conseil national des imams qui sera
chargé je cite un de labelliser les
imams exerçant en france
je cite encore la charte les signataires
doivent rejeter clairement toute
ingérence de l'étranger dans la gestion
de leur mosquée et la mission de leurs
imams la mission de leur imam est ce que
ce n'est pas un petit peu paradoxal
quand on sait que voilà de nombreuses
fédérations sont justement financé par
les pays étrangers il n'y a pas un
conflit d'intérêt oui je suis d'accord
avec vous il y a trois pays qui ont des
imams en france l'âge et les lads
jockeys et le maroc
mais c'est zimbra et sont venus il ya
désaccord signale que l'on voit français
à ce qu' il manque d'imams maintenant le
présent à public souhaite qu'ils
puissent plus hardiment à partir de 2023
c'est son choix et il est libre mais ce
sont des images qui sont venus soit des
cinq ans maintenant et l'ébriété il ya
des pays qui financent sens qu'elle
paris les mêmes chantiers par l'algérie
qui va rentrer chez eux s'ils y aura
plus de financement au niveau des
humains acidh étrangers donc comment
fait-on ça veut dire que cette charte va
de toute manière avoir du mal finalement
être appliqué dans dans le concret oui
enfin être appliquée parce que je vous
dis dans un château des paragraphes dans
cette chatte existait déjà il existe le
problème principal pour nous pour la
plupart des musulmans que j'ai eus
pascal oger
hélas pas à consulter les mêmes de
terrain le problème bien c'est le
respect de la république ne respectant
les valeurs de la république annoncé à
chaque fois des besoins procès à noter
la réussite et oui la laïcité et toute
la laïcité
la laïcité c'est la non ingérence dans
les affaires de cul les parcelles gères
tu clairement musulmans quant à moi mais
de moussaoui président du cfcm
sur le perron de l'anil de l'elysée
salue l'unité retrouvée au sein du
conseil français du culte musulman alors
ça veut dire quoi que il faut lui
demander à lui moi je sais qu'il n'y a
pas d'unité a pas d'unité banc il a
voulu essayer
si vous voulez de rassurer mais il n'y a
pas d'unité faut être clair il faut pas
quand même raconté n'importe quoi
je suis faut pas mentir aux gens que je
prenais c'est quelqu'un de quoi je pense
pas qu'il vaut mais il essaie d'arrondir
les angles
voilà c'est tout parce que hier il ya eu
un débat entre fédérations y en a vu
qu'il n'y avait pas d'entente et ça a
été prouvé ce matin à l'elysée aux trois
fédérations importantes et à présent
clairement à des écrits il y avait une
pression de l'exécutif pour que les
fédérations signe ses textes un c'est
pas moi qui l'inventé si certains ne
seront pas cette charte nous en tirerons
les conséquences avait avertit emmanuel
macron est ce que c'est une forme de
pression vous avez peut-être sentis pour
signer ce texte
je sais ça fait 25 ans que dans le culte
je n'ai jamais vu une des pressions
exercées sur l'islam et les musulmans
ils peuvent avoir des débats de prison
la république à la il a un agenda il a
un calendrier il veut aller vite mais je
pense c'est pas en allant vite corriger
le problème
il faut pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation merci beaucoup avait la
dcri d'avoir été avec nous délégué
général du sell d'avoir été en direct
sur arte france
des bâtiments vont encore sortir de
terre dans les colonies de cisjordanie
l'état hébreu a donné son feu vert hier
pour la construction de 780 logements
sur ce territoire palestinien une
expansion des colonies israéliennes
dénoncée notamment par les européens et
la main medjahed pour l'autorité
palestinienne israël joue la montre pour
construire des colonies avant le départ
de donald trump de la maison blanche
il faut dire que son successeur joe
biden voit d'un mauvais oeil la
construction de ces logements dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés
le président américain élu qui s'est
même engagé à intensifier les efforts en
vue de la création d'un état palestinien
une politique à l'encontre de celle de
donald trump pour l'organisation anti
colonisation la paix maintenant
israël cherche clairement à provoquer
l'administration byden la construction
et les approbations en cours en
cisjordanie sont très mauvaises pour
israël car elle empêche qu'on la
possibilité d'une solution à deux états
dans un accord de paix et je pense que
ce n'est pas un hasard si cette annonce
arrive maintenant à la veille du
changement de l'administration aux états
unis mais benjamin netanyahu veut
signifier à joe biden qu'il va devoir
s'occuper des problèmes israélien s'il
veut réussir son mandat d arrêt chose
est sûre si la construction des 780
logements en cisjordanie est pourtant
contraire au droit international
chose que rappelle notamment londres et
l'union européenne
nous appelons le gouvernement israélien
à revenir sur ses décisions et à faire
preuve de responsabilité pour
reconstruire la confiance entre les
parties nécessaires pour aboutir à une
reprise des négociations israélo
palestiniennes
le royaume uni est gravement préoccupée
par la décision du gouvernement
israélien d'approuver la construction de
780 nouvelles colonies dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés
les colonies sont illégales au regard du
droit international et risque de
compromettre la viabilité physique de la
solution des deux états nous demandons
que leur construction à jérusalem est et
ailleurs en cisjordanie cesse
immédiatement
à l'heure actuelle plus de 450 mille
israéliens résident dans des colonies en
cisjordanie un territoire où vivent près
de trois millions de palestiniens depuis
le début de l'occupation par l'armée
israélienne en 1967 la colonisation
s'est poursuivie sous tous les
gouvernements israéliens
mais sous l'impulsion du premier
ministre benyamin netanyahu et de son
allié à washington donald trump
l'expansion des colonies s'est accélérée
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis tel aviv en israël avec jacques
benillouche journaliste indépendant
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jaca benillouche merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
cette autorisation elle intervient en
pleine campagne électorale pour les
législatives du mois de mars mais amy
netanyahu et benny ganz qui veulent
donner des gages aux colons et à leur
soutien selon vous la situation est
assez tendue netanyahu qui effectivement
d'après les sondages est en tête de tous
les partis avec eux en gros entre 28 et
32 sièges sur 120 mais il a eu de
grandes difficultés à pouvoir créer une
coalition
il a deux concurrents directs issus
d'ailleurs les deux du likoud
le premier c'est un art tony bennett qui
est un jeu religieux sioniste qui est
très attaché aux colonies en israël et
d'autres en cisjordanie et d'autre part
vous avez guidéon saar qui vient à peine
de quitter le parti et qui fait partie
de la droite du likoud
donc ce sont donc deux opposants de
droite et donc d'un camion a besoin de
vider les sens de leurs oeufs leurs
électeurs en faisant des eaux prenant
des décisions qui satisfont les
éventuels colo et donc à l'heure
actuelle natanyahou et condamné est
condamné à faire la courte échelle à
tous les extrémistes de droite il y a
trois petits partis à l'extrême droite
qu'il est en train de convaincre de le
rejoindre
est ce qu il veut c c est
essentiellement empêcher les deux
parties de se réunir pour lui prendre la
place
allons donc il est prêt à tout il est
prêt à tout et il a donc fait cette
c'est cette décision de créer des
colonies la même choisi une un symbole
dans une d'économie il y a quelques
jours il y a eu un assassinat d'une
femme qui habitait dans une des colonies
qui s'appelait l1 mais lâché
et bien pour punir les et les et les
palestiniens qui sont dans les environs
eh bien il a décidé de créer 100
logements dans cette habitation une
sorte de vengeance contre l'al contre
éventuellement contre l' assassinat
alors on ne pense jamais nié leur donnez
moi même et c'est intéressant ce que
vous nous dites parce que ça concerne
pas nécessairement toutes les
populations d'israël c'est une galère
vous l'avez expliqué politique comment
réagissent les israéliens à cette
nouvelle par exemple les israéliens sont
je dirais un petit peu éteint je dirais
à l'heure actuelle ils ont toujours
parce que la majorité de la population a
viré à la droite pour ne pas dire à
l'extrême droite la gauche n'existe plus
le centre est a explosé en quatre ou
cinq unités
il ne lui ne peut plus gouverner et donc
eu ce qu'on sait c'est que la population
est résignée la population est résignée
elle sait qu'elle ne pourra pas éviter
l'arrivée d'un gouvernement de droite
voire d'extrême droite parce que les
deux concurrents de natanyahou sont des
gens d'extrême droite dire qu'ils sont
d'extrême droite c'est qu'il refuse la
création d'un état palestinien
ils sont pour l'injection total de la
cisjordanie
ils sont pour l'interdiction de donner
la nationalité israélienne aux futurs
habitants qui seraient annexés
et donc c'est vraiment les oeufs durs du
parti likoud qui viendrait au pouvoir et
de l'autre côté c'est des querelles
intestines
c'est la guerre des ego je dirais parce
que tout le monde devait présidents de
parti tout le monde est chef de parti et
il voit pas l'intérêt que l'intérêt
primordial c'est de se liguer contre
n'atteignant et bien d'autres sont
contraints de vous expliquer cette
radicalisation de l'opinion vous nous
décrivez on sait quand on sort de quatre
ans de mandat de
nan tron qui a été en grand soutien
envers miami netanyahu est ce que ceci
explique cela on ça n'a rien à voir
et justement c'est parce que tu rappes a
beaucoup aidé israël vous savez que
pendant la mandature de 2,3 puis à 27
milles logements qui ont été créés et
donc très mme c'était un peu le dieu
d'israël et le jour où il a été élu ça a
été je dirais une journée de deuil
parmi les populations de droite et donc
il est évident que pour eux ce que
faisait bien le train était la meilleure
chose pour le pays et de l'autre côté
eh bien on peut dire que il n'y a pas eu
de réveil du centre ou de la gauche et
donc à partir de ce moment là le pays
est en train de virer de plus en plus
vers l'extrême droite
et malheureusement pour beaucoup de
populations du centre et de droite et
ivo pratiquement décidé certains de ne
pas aller voter parce qu'ils savent que
c'est sans issue
la situation est critique mais ils ne
sont pas prêts à voter c'est pour ça
qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya beaucoup de
deux parties qui essaient de raviver
l'élan de les populations pour leur
demander de voter et de ne pas baisser
les bras mais on ne peut rien faire
c'est la constatation qui se fait les
sondages donnent à peu près 60 au niveau
de la droite
plus de soixante cinq votants au niveau
du likoud très peu mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que si ça continue dans cette aide
dans sous cette forme
eh bien on va avoir un gouvernement
d'extrême droite dirigé par nathalie
bennett et guidéon saar auxquels se
joindront quelques autres partis du
centre qui clôtureront la coalition mais
ils n'auront pas beaucoup droit à la
parole parce que le centre n'existe plus
la gauche n'existe plus comme en france
le parti travailliste a disparu de
l'écran de 2 des élections des élections
il ya juste un petit parti d'extrême
gauche ou de gauche historique qui est
le meretz avec cinq députés
il fera pas grand chose
sinon de marquer la présence continue
d'une f gauche dans le pays
nous en sommes là et donc effectivement
nous virons de plus en plus vers
l'extrême droit et c'est un peu triste
pour beaucoup de gens de la population
de voir que c'est selon de la qui dirige
accompagné accompagné faut le dire par
les orthodoxes religieux qui eux avec
entre 16 avec 16 députés font la pluie
et le beau temps imposent leurs lois
imposent les lois à la coalition
imposent les lois à tous les
gouvernements qui sont là parce que
c'est eux qui change le l'essence même
de cette coalition
merci jacques benillouche d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes indépendants en
direct d'israël pour vu de l'extérieur
ce soir et dans le reste de l'actualité
toujours au proche orient que va changer
l'arrivée de joe biden au pouvoir quels
impacts justement pour les palestiniens
on sait que donald trump on vient de le
dire a été un allié indéfectible
d'israël un contexte qui a resserré les
liens entre les mouvements palestiniens
rivaux le hamas et le fatah des
élections législatives et
présidentielles vont d'ailleurs se tenir
en cisjordanie et à gaza clément barbe
et les palestiniens ne manqueront pas de
date cette année le 22 mai les
législatives suivies par la
présidentielle le 31 juillet une annonce
importante faite par le président
mahmoud abbas
quinze ans que ces scrutins n'ont pas pu
se tenir dans les territoires
palestiniens et dans la bande de gaza
quinze ans de divisions entre le fatah
et le hamas
les mouvements palestiniens rivaux sont
restés à couteau tiré jusqu'au mois de
septembre dernier moment où ils ont
enfin pu s'entendre sur l'organisation
d'élections
une évolution saluée par le fatah et le
hamas le hamas se félicite de la
publication de décret présidentiel
relatifs à la conduite des élections
législatives présidentielle et du
conseil national la masse a travaillé
pendant de nombreux mois à la
préparation du climat national à
que nous soyons prêts pour des élections
sérieuse ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est
engager un dialogue national afin de
trouver toutes les solutions nécessaires
pour un véritable processus électoral
qui exprime la volonté de notre peuple
palestinien mahmoud abbas a promis la
tenue d'élections à plusieurs reprises
sans jamais concrétiser sa promesse
pourtant pour beaucoup de gazaouis la
tenue de ces scrutins ne donnerait plus
de légitimité aux dirigeants
palestiniens si vous demandez à qui
coule dans la rue il vous dira qu'ils
souhaitent une élection tant que l'élu
prend soin de nous et répond à nos
demandes
parce qu'ici nous avons été malmenés
quel que soit le parti élu que ce soit
pour la présidence où le conseil
législatif l'important est qu'il y ait
des élections que la situation
économique change et améliore la vie de
tous sauf tant qu'il n'ya pas de
réconciliation entre le fatah et le
hamas
les élections sont impossibles car s'il
y avait une réconciliation
il y aurait un accord entre les deux
parties en tant que gazaouis je veux que
les élections mettre fin à la division
entre le fatah et le hamas
une rupture entre les deux mouvements
palestiniens qui remonte à 2007 année où
le ramasse prend le contrôle de la bande
de gaza au prix d'un putsch armés à
l'origine de cette décision
la victoire du hamas aux législatives
des élections qui on veut ni mais les
relations entre les deux camps depuis la
vie politique palestinienne est figé et
beaucoup espèrent retrouver le droit de
choisir leurs dirigeants et
représentants
pressez la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]